Welcome to The Explainer.
You know, today we're tackling
something that feels really
personal for a lot of us.
What in the world happened to
the American Dream?
It just feels like the goal
posts have moved like way down
the field and the whole game
feels a little rigged, doesn't
it?
So that's the big question we're
asking.
Is the dream actually dead, or
has it been replaced by
something else?
A fantasy that was never really
meant to come true in the 1st
place?
And this idea right here, man,
it just gets to the absolute
heart of the problem.
A fantasy with no staircase, A
dream without a ladder.
It's like we're constantly being
shown this incredible
destination, right?
But nobody's handing out a map.
Nobody's showing us how to get
there.
So that brings us right to our
first section, a dream without a
ladder.
And here we're really going to
unpack this massive disconnect,
you know, between the vision of
success we see plastered
everywhere and the actual
practical steps available to,
well, most of us.
I mean, just open up your phone.
The dream we're being sold
today, it's not a modest little
house in the suburbs.
Nope, it's a penthouse.
It's a private jet.
It's this life of just
effortless, perfect excess.
And here's the kicker, It's not
sold to us like it's a movie.
It's sold as the actual life of
someone who, you know, might
even claim they're just like you
and me.
And that really is the question,
isn't it?
If that's the new bar for
success, how is a normal person
supposed to get there?
Like, where are the rungs on
that ladder?
Because when you really look
closely at this new dream, there
aren't any.
They're just gone.
OK, so to really get how
disconnected today's dream
feels, we've got to rewind the
clock a bit.
Let's talk about the original
dream.
A chicken in every pot.
Its power came from something
totally different.
See, the old American dream was
so powerful because it was,
well, it was modest.
It was tangible.
It was about stability, a steady
job, paying off your mortgage,
and just that quiet confidence
that your kids would do a little
bit better than you did.
You could actually picture
yourself building it, you know,
piece by piece.
And that simple phrase just
captured the whole spirit of it
perfectly.
A chicken in every pot.
It wasn't promising A feast
every night or a fancy car.
No, it was a promise of
something way more fundamental.
Dignity, security, and just
knowing that your hard work
would pay off in a life that
wasn't a constant struggle.
You know, this phrase has a
pretty wild history.
It actually starts way back in
16th century France with a king
who just wished every peasant
could have a chicken for their
Sunday dinner.
Fast forward a few centuries and
it gets picked up for a 1928
political ad in the US all about
prosperity.
But then just a few years later,
bam, the Great Depression hits
and the whole thing becomes this
bitter joke, a symbol of a
promise that was just shattered.
And that whole history, it
really reveals the old dreams.
Secret weapon.
It wasn't about luxury at all.
It was about plausibility.
It was a goal.
You could believe him.
A ladder you could actually see
and climb one steady rung at a
time.
And that feeling, that
plausibility, that's exactly
what seems to be missing today.
So if that ladder was so sturdy,
what happened?
Where did it go?
Well, that brings us to our next
section.
The ladder collapses because
somewhere between that old
school dream and right now, the
rungs on that ladder started to
crack.
They started to break apart.
And it wasn't just one thing,
you know, it was more like a
slow motion demolition for
decades.
Wages just flattened out.
They stopped keeping up.
And at the same time, the price
tags on the core building blocks
of a middle class life, a house,
healthcare, education, they just
started to skyrocket, moving
further and further out of reach
for so many people.
Now, if all that was a slow
burn, then 2008 was the
explosion, the financial crisis.
It wasn't just some economic
downturn, it was a massive
psychological blow.
I mean, for a whole generation,
it felt like the basic rules of
the game were just a complete
lie.
I mean, just think about it.
The family home that was
supposed to be the ultimate
symbol of security, right?
The cornerstone of middle class
wealth.
And all of a sudden, it turned
into a trapdoor.
Millions of people watch their
equity just disappear overnight.
The very foundation of that old
dream turned out to be shaky,
and a whole lot of faith
crumbled right along with it.
So with that old dream feeling
so fragile, so unreliable, a
massive void opened up.
A crisis of faith, really, And
something brand new and
incredibly powerful rushed right
in to fill it.
We're calling it the fantasy on
your screen, and it's this super
seductive alternative that was
waiting for us right there in
our pockets.
And here's the whole disconnect
in a nutshell.
On one side, you've got the
fantasy on your feed, right?
Penthouses, private jets, the
whole deal.
On the other side, you've got
the quiet reality for most
people.
Cooking dinner at home, driving
a normal car, stressing out
about student loans.
One of those is a total
spectacle.
The other one?
It's plausible, but it's kind of
boring.
So guess which one gets all the
attention?
And while all this is happening,
the very definition of what it
even means to be rich has been
quietly inflating.
You know, $1,000,000 used to be
the big benchmark, then somehow
the target became 10 million.
And now, Now the cultural goal
post has shifted all the way out
to 100 million.
It feels like the finish line
just keeps getting pushed
further and further down the
track.
So where does all of this leave
us?
Well, it leaves a lot of people
in a really tough spot.
We're calling it trapped between
two illusions.
Basically, we're caught between
two powerful, super misleading,
and ultimately pretty damaging
ideas about what success is even
supposed to look like.
And these are the two lies that
kind of work together like a 1-2
punch.
First you have the fantasy lie
that tells you to aim for this
impossible, glamorous life.
And then right behind it, you
have the consumer lie, which
whispers in your ear that your
daily habits, you know, your
spending, your burn rate, they
don't really matter because hey,
the system's rigged anyway,
right?
It's a perfect trap.
Go chase the fantasy and don't
even bother building a real
ladder.
And maybe that's the real
tragedy in all of this.
It's not just that the old
stable dream is harder to get
to.
It's that it's been replaced by
a fantasy with no path forward.
And a dream without a ladder,
well, that's not an inspiration.
It's a taunt just hanging up
there in the sky, always just
out of reach.
Which leaves us all with one
last really crucial question.
If this fantasy that we're being
sold is a total dead end, what
should we be dreaming of
instead?
You know, if we had to build a
brand new ladder for a new
American dream right now, what
would the rungs even be made of?
That's something to think about.
Thanks for joining us on The
Explainer.